[Music]
foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday March 22nd I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
seems like every day we're hearing about
a new use case for artificial
intelligence from writing cover letters
to coding and as Ai and other emerging
Technologies continue to hit the market
top of mind for many European officials
is regulation at this year's mwc the
mobile tech show formerly known as
Mobile World Congress The Wall Street
Journal senior personal Tech columnist
Joanna Stern sat down with karame
artigas Spain's Secretary of State for
digitization and artificial intelligence
they talked about the eu's approach to
AI the metaverse and privacy regulations
here are highlights from their
conversation
so AI is a big topic right now of any
industry really
Chachi BT has taken consumer world right
now by by storm in the sense that people
are interacting with computers in a
different way when you think about Ai
and you have a big background in Big
Data are you shocked this to sort of
come along so quickly and are you
thinking a lot about the implications
for consumers and your citizens
absolutely the thing AI together with I
mentioned Quantum Computing or new
technologies are key disruptive
Technologies all the area of deep Tech
has important focus on also the public
investment of the government of Spain so
in Spain we are leading I would say
development of AI in three important
areas one sustainable and fair Ai and we
are leading the sandbox of the future
European regulation and artificial
intelligence we are leading all the work
with the industry to trying to prevent
that the AI is developed with biases we
also have developed a charter of digital
rights which we put special rights on AI
like the Rhino to be discriminated by an
algorithm or the right to have a second
human opinion we are also very
interested fit in international plan we
have launch called the national plan for
green algorithms chagibit is an example
of how is developed but with a high
consumption on energy which is not
sustainable long term the same way like
web3 is not sustainable today so we want
to develop green AI by Design not
worried at the end of the value chain
that the data centers are fit with a
renewable energy we want to find better
ways to develop
artificial intelligence which is
sustainable and in particular in Spain
when to have the leadership on AI
developed in a Spanish language
all the artificial intelligence is
developed in English or in Chinese in
fact we've made the same prompt in
English and chegbt and then they make
the same plant in Spanish it gives you
different answers
so there's important Gap we have a 600
million
Spanish speakers in the world and Spain
is determined to to lead the development
of AI Solutions and of course language
models in Spanish the EU has been at the
Forefront of so much of consumer privacy
gdpr Etc are there updates that you
think need to be made there with this
quick coming of AI and consumer use of
AI of course you has a very important
set of Regulation that is in place now
the Digital Services act the digital
Market act they tend to limit the
excessive power of the current digital
platforms on data users we have
sometimes have that economy within data
protection and data your usability that
is not that anymore we can reuse data
but with privacy and control we need
also to define the way we interact with
data with third countries with trust
called free data flows with trust and
that's important International agreement
on that and now we're going to lead the
development of the European regulation
on artificial intelligence we put some
limits for example for I would say
facial recognition in Open Spaces
another example is newer Technologies
where Spain is very concerned about part
of the Charter Digital rights focus on
non-invasive neurotechnologies the right
not to be augmented by by a cheap or by
a narrator technology device the right
to protect the free will so there are a
lot of important topics that if we
cannot solve before technology is
broadly adopted an example is metal
press we should regulate metaverse
before it becomes mainstream because
otherwise it will happen like with
climate change there are some harm that
we will not be able to revert back and
that's our main concern while we're on
the metaverse I'm going to ask you
because I'm asking every guest here to
to end the sentence for me the metaverse
is you have to fill in the blank The
Meta receives the convergence of several
Technologies like 5G virtual reality
augmented reality to create immersive
experiences that are very good in the
future in terms of for example New
Opportunities For
Education opportunities that can be help
sustainability like the digital twins
but also poses serious risks and we need
to protect the uh concentration of data
of all that different types of data in
the hands of companies and for me
metaverse has always used to have a foot
on the physical world a foot on the
ground and I'm just very fascinated in
hearing this term about digital Twins
and what this future of us each
digitally being recreated means for for
both regulation but also as you're
thinking about it for the future now is
applied industry so you have here an
engine you have a nuclear plant you need
to test everything physically when you
have a prototype you have a digital
reproduction of the existing physical
device that is synchronized with sensors
so if there is a problem no maintenance
you can test it on the device and then
you put it uh on the real divide in the
real and the engine but there is also
digital twins of human being we are
starting in Europe developing the first
digital twin of the heart digital skin
and for example that would be as good as
if I'm trying to test
um a procedure or cancer treatment which
is innovative I can test it before in
the Twin and before applying to me if I
want to give up smoking I don't smoke
but imagine I I should give up smoking
or a diet I can test my diet on the
digital twin several strategies and then
the one that works is the one they apply
from it another important digital twin
is digital twin of the world in terms of
climate prevention and there is also
important initiatives at European level
to have a digital twin of the earth you
mentioned facial recognition how do you
think that can be used responsibly
responsibly and I know that the EU is
looking at a ban on that where do you
fall on that and again is it you've
mentioned a couple of times here the
responsibility and being able to get
ahead of it what are you doing there you
know that precisely this is one of the
hot topics on the future European
regulation and AI that is now is being
discussed in the tree logs the tree
looks are once you have the position of
the commission then you have the council
you have the parliament so they need to
come to an agreement the position of the
community of the commission is to ban
facial recognition in public open spaces
so if I'm going to demonstration for
black lives matter you don't need the
government doesn't need to know that I
was there that has happened in the U.S
happening in China in Europe we have a
different approach we think that data is
not on the hands of the companies not in
the hands of the government it must be
under control of civil and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing but a quick
reminder before we go we want to hear
your questions about generative
artificial intelligence For an upcoming
episode do you have questions about AI
programs like chat GPT Microsoft's new
Bing search or mid-journey email us a
voice recording to tnb at wsj.com or
leave us a voicemail on
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you I'm Julie Chang for the Wall
Street Journal thank you for listening
[Music]
thank you